bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france aujourd'hui
la pauvreté touche l'ensemble de la
population libanaise bon sens madame oui
c'est une très bien résumé la situation
dans votre reportage en fait c'est une
catastrophe économique sans nom c'est
une vraie descente aux enfers conte à
laquelle on est confronté au quotidien
ici au liban
c'est à dire que vraiment comme vous
allez expliquer c'est une des plus
graves crises économiques depuis la
moitié du 19e siècle
c'est quand même quelque chose de
d'inédits d'incroyable et qui se voit au
quotidien ici au liban est pas qu à
beyrouth en fait dans tout pays et cela
touche toutes les communautés présentes
au liban c'est une réelle catastrophe et
ce qu'ils touchent évidemment bien sûr
toutes les tranches de la population que
ce soient les plus jeunes ou les plus
comment est-ce que la situation
humanitaire a évolué ces derniers mois
eh bien écoutez elle a voulu
malheureusement dans le bon sens on est
vraiment face à une énorme crise
humanitaire c'est à dire que les enfants
par exemple ne peuvent plus se rendre à
l'école des familles vivre au quotidien
comme on a vu de votre reportage cette
femme qui ne peut plus acheter justement
les produits nécessaires pour ses filles
pour leur règle enfin je veux dire on
est on ne peut absolument plus se
fournir en biens de première nécessité
même les médicaments il ya une très in
énorme crise une tendinite ne parle de
pénurie de médicaments au liban qui est
gravissime de même par exemple le simple
médicaments pour contrer la douleur on
n'en trouve plus on n'en trouve plus et
c'est une catastrophe
même des biens de première nécessité
mais pour se nourrir plus une famille
que nous rencontrons au quotidien avec
aso aux chrétiens d'orient ne peuvent
plus boucler les fins de mois donc c'est
une vraie catastrophe à laquelle est
confrontée la fameuse suite du
moyen-orient mais malheureusement la
suite du moyen-orient aujourd'hui et
bientôt vous arrivez à aider les
populations qui font appel à vous
écouter de différentes manières mais
comme vous avez parlé également parlé on
est on est l'accent énormément sur la
jeunesse en fait sur les jeunes sur les
enfants malheureusement énormément
d'écoles risque de fermer à la rentrée
faute de moyens alors évidemment les
écoles ans elles subissent les
différentes crises qui sont en train
d'avoir lieu au liban et à d'abord eu
une explosion
en fait l'année dernière donc le 4 août
2020 avec si on détruit énormément
d'établissements ya à peu près cent
vingt-huit tablissements à beyrouth qui
ont subi des dommages à la suite de
l'explosion
imaginez même d'un point de vue
psychologique pour les enfants de voir
en fait l'homme
à se détruire leurs bureaux détruits et
ne plus avoir la possibilité de se
rendre à l'école et malheureusement avec
la crise du dollar c'est à dire qu'il
faut se rendre compte que la valeur de
la livre libanaise a perdu 90% de sa
valeur face au dollar
je veux dire si c'est une dévaluation
mais catastrophique
ce qui fait que les familles des coûts
ne peuvent plus financer la
scolarisation des enfants
c'est pour ça qu'elle souhaite chrétiens
d'orient du coup on s'engage pour
justement alléger au maximum les budgets
des familles en finançant la
scolarisation des enfants et nous allons
également venir en aide à plus de 20
écoles au liban qui se retrouve une
situation catastrophique comme je vous
ai dit et je le répète 80% des
établissements catholiques risque de
fermer à la rentrée
qu'est-ce que de ne pas pouvoir ouvrir
sachant qu'il faut savoir que deux tiers
des enfants au liban qu'ils soient
musulmans ou chrétiens vont dans des
écoles catholiques
cela concerne vraiment toute la
population et on a vraiment très peur de
ce qui va se passer à la rentrée va
falloir se les membres recevoir de
l'aide pour assurer une scolarité
décente à tous les enfants libanais
justement quel regard est ce que vous
vous portez sur la communauté
internationale qui conditionne son aide
au lancement de réformes contre la
corruption et le clientélisme au liban
j'ai écouté il serait temps il serait
temps malheureusement le liban
aujourd'hui subi en fait les choix
politiques et les acteurs politiques de
ces quarante dernières années
il faut pas regarder uniquement ses 4,5
il faut voir les choses dans sa
globalité et malheureusement oui nous
sommes confrontés à une classe politique
qui donne l'impression en tout cas
d'avoir en fait abandonner le peuple
d'avoir en fait tout simplement eu envie
de tout simplement pu répondre aux
attentes du peuple
et d'ailleurs comme vous l'avez dit ça
fait dix mois qu'on n'a pas de
gouvernement les libanais craque
complètement des rencontres qu'il y en a
la plus grave crise de l'histoire de
livres et on n'a même pas un
gouvernement à la tête du pays pour
pouvoir répondre à l'urgence qui est à
l'urgence humanitaire à l'urgence
économique à l'autre sens sociétal à
l'urgence de l'éducation des enfants
on a l'impression que le bateau
malheureusement nos bêtes le liban est
un bateau qui part à la dérive
il n'y a plus de capitaine et personne
n'est capable justement de prendre les
prendre en main le pays pour apporter
enfin une réponse à l'urgence qui a lieu
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne arthur
longtemps je rappelle que vous êtes chef
de mission au liban pour sos chrétiens
d'orient